being a musical artists stay true to why
you wanted to do it in the first place
sometimes things get misunderstood or
misconstrued and just don't let it break
you your artistry is more important I'm
Rita Ora I am a singer and I'm 27 years
old I was brought up in West London but
I was born in Pristina Kosovo I moved to
London when I was 1 and my parents to
learn English when they moved us here
and we were a refugee family when you're
a kid you obviously don't realize how
hard your parents work and as I got
older I kind of started to understand
the situation and of course they're like
go to school and you know get a degree
and which is incredible but my gene and
my genetic in me I was kind of like I
can't do that and I wanted to be a
singer which of course gave my parents a
heart attack what made me really want to
succeed was that I didn't have a choice
I didn't know what else I wanted to do
and I didn't want to end up without an
answer when I left school and you had to
do something that was gonna help me in
the future so I obviously got a job and
then I would work in a recording studio
I was really just begging to anything
like right and they'd have artists in
there you know like Jason Mraz and Craig
David people would kind of come in and
I'd be like my school uniform trying to
get involved and then through there I
was asked to kind of sink backing vocals
for them and I was like yes and it got
my foot in the door and then I got a
production deal and then through that
production deal I met a lot of label
heads and through that I got signed by
jay-z with me you know there's some
amazing entertainers that I feel do one
amazing thing like music or acting I
wanted to do
at all I feel like we're in an era where
entertainment can be so diverse with
being able to be an actress and being
able to be on TV and present and be a
coach or a judge I still put out an
album people like Lady gaga doing you
and Justin Timberlake it's been doing it
for years putting out music and being in
movies I think it's really cool that we
get to do you know a variety of things
and entertainment forms 30 under 30 it
means everything to me it makes me feel
like what I'm doing is right and it
makes me feel confident that I want to
just keep doing what I'm doing so thank
you very much for giving me that tap on
the shoulder
[Music]